i was one of those [ __ ] who would
like go on model mayhem and be like
mommy
i want to shoot with photographers and
my mom would be like
no absolutely not look at all the nude
pictures on this photographer's website
i'd be like i
don't care mom they want to shoot with
me nobody wants to shoot with me
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming queen
former oakton cougar and girl who gave a
hand job while seeing black snake moan
in theaters elise morales and with us
today we have an author
a sex educator she's the host of the hot
brain podcast and ceo of spectrum
boutique
but before all of that she was a
graduate of james
hubert blake high school it's zoe liggin
yeah um go bengals jbhs
2010 oh the bangles that's kind of
that's kind of nice it was actually
pretty nice like white it was a white
tiger
with blue eyes how adorable um
ours was literally just it was a cougar
but
they clearly just stole the nittany lion
from penn state and put it on
all of our stuff yeah i def you
definitely notice a lot of similar
mascots when you uh
line up all the schools
high schools don't need to be that
creative no
no they definitely don't they were like
five mascots in
rotation and one is just like an irish
man
whoa i went to a quaker school
uh from first through eighth grade and
our we were the trees
oh that's very sweet these peaceful
trees
all right well zoe we are we're from not
far
apart you're a maryland gal i'm i'm
right now i'm going to pull up the first
photo that you sent to us
yeah that's me so we have uh
you you look clearly in a cheer
capacity at this point are we are we
cheerleading
so you know it's easier to just say
cheerleading it was actually a dance
team
called palms you know about the palms
okay so cheerleading is gymnastics based
and palms is dance-based so we didn't do
any
stunts we just did like turns and jumps
and leaps and like
cheerleaders would be out on the field
or on the basketball
court through the whole game and we
would be in the bleachers
and then perform at halftime obviously a
huge
difference you were coordinated with the
cheerleaders
yes as well see that's interesting
because my high school
my high school had cheerleaders and then
we had a dance team
and the dance team like superseded the
cheerleaders in popularness
unfortunately it was that way for us to
we actually i mean not to humblebrag
we got second place out of
the 30 35 schools in montgomery county
my
freshman and sophomore year and then my
two upper class menu years we got first
place in the counties
so we were hot [ __ ] and
i was popular because i was on dance
team
but out of all the girls on dance team i
was the weird one
who would not invite to the parties you
know what i mean i think that that's
definitely demonstrated in the photo
we're looking at here
everyone was like oh zoey for the
listener
yeah it's it's sort of there's like a
demonic energy that's coming from the
photo very scary
are you texting on a flip phone yeah i
was actually just about to
focus my attention on that next because
i believe that is
the voyager phone that it was like it
would open
a hot dog style that i remember
when that came out that was a that was a
big phone
i felt like i had a mini computer little
did i know
smartphones were i was
i'm so thankful i did not have a
smartphone in high school my life would
be
would have been ruined probably yeah it
i
my attention span from getting one in
college is
already [ __ ] but do you remember i
kind of miss
like the waves of phones that would come
through where i was like okay
one christmas everyone gets the razor i
had a pink one
i had the pink one um and then the boys
would get the silver one
obviously yeah that's the more adult uh
razer like if you're like a businessman
maybe you have a
yeah but if you're a silly little girl
you have to have a pink one
people would like put it like it like
like this in our in our sophie shorts
yeah remember those shorts where you
would like
like one roll is like normal
and then like two rolls you're getting
like a little scandalous yeah what do
you mean okay
oh yeah i mean well so my school also
always had the fingertip
length rule uh for sure
right what if you have really long or
really short arms i have very short
arms my arms basically just reach my
hips so
i mean it was it's so funny to me
because i feel like now people talk
about the high school dress codes kind
of for what they are
at least there's more awareness of how
they're like just
policing young girls but at the time it
was just like
this menace that followed me all the
time i was always getting dress coded
because i also
yeah because i always wanted to wear
skirts and stuff and like i just
i was always getting dress coded i think
the most scandalous outfit i wore was
probably my actual palms uniform because
i
swear to you like it would be like
it would essentially be a mock
turtleneck and long sleeves but then the
skirt
is literally like anus length and then
and then you're just wearing little boy
shorts underneath
the little turtleneck is cute though
we've got sort of a
more traditional cheer pick here it's
funny because
at some point i certainly went through
my facebook and
mass deleted and untagged so this is a
surviving relic
um we took a lot of pictures in
chemistry class
that was chemistry class we had a very
chill
hot teacher and she was just very cool
she let us uh
you know we would bring our digital
cameras to school back then
oh of course you know you would slip
yourself my pictures to myspace
yeah absolutely although i i would say
that was like
the first or second year of me being on
facebook probably
but um yeah like i love that picture
because i look like such a [ __ ] in that
picture
um and i'm sure
you know like it accurately represents
my obnoxiousness
but when i look at this photo i just see
a girl who is trying
so hard to fit in like i was
normal and preppy because i
felt like such a [ __ ] outcast
i was like get the north face get the
uggs
just wear what everybody else wears and
then like
you can just blend in did you at this
point were you like
secretly alt like under under the table
like listening
to different music animal collectives
yeah like
that's exactly what i mean yeah i
actually
i would say my my taste in music was
like alt
beginning my freshman year in high
school because
i had like the guys i i was crushing on
had alt music taste
all the guys i liked were like potheads
who would just like take photography
class
and just like chill in the dark room
they would like
smoke weed out of sprite cans behind the
baseball field and i was very straight
edge
i would not have called it straight edge
but it was
because of dance team essentially all
the other girls on dance team were
drinking
and smoking weed which is also why i was
unpopular because i
was a rule follower i did not want to
break the rules
because i didn't want to get kicked off
of dance team and like girls would be
coming to practice hung over all the
time and i was like
oh man i was like i wish they invited me
to the party but at least i'm not
hungover
so who was your crew at this time like
were you hanging
out so just kind of like absolutely
nobody i uh i dated
a a man or i guess he was a man by the
end of the relationship but i dated a
guy who was three years older than me
and also went to my high school
um he was incredibly emotionally abusive
and i spent all my time with him i
stopped seeing all of my friends
i had some friends at the beginning of
freshman year
and part of it was like me being
straight edge but another part of it was
like
i was eating a sleazy abusive guy
and i think other people just like
could be like that's kind of a weird
vibe like something weird is going on
here let's just like leave her alone
maybe
yeah because i think teenagers have a
hard time
recognizing why something doesn't feel
right so they're just looking at a
relationship and they're like
there's something weird about that guy
or just like i don't like her boyfriend
but not realizing like
oh this is actually a bad man
oh definitely intervene in his presence
in our world
yeah how did you meet him and get
like like did was it was he like hanging
out with just the other stoner guys
or he knew some of the girls on dance
team who were upperclassmen
upper class people i don't know how yeah
that gender neutral today um upper-class
person
there you go i uh
i went to some of the like high school
theater productions before
i actually went to the school and it
just so ha
and i went to my friend's older sister's
musical performances and he was them and
as a you know not quite yet going to the
school girl i was like oh my god he's so
hot
oh yeah i mean that's a recipe for a
disaster
yeah i found a fantasy it was
idolization of like
a random guy who was incredibly
awful yeah i i relate to that super hard
because i
i had one very bad relationship in high
school with
a person who definitely abusive not a
good person at all and i felt
i don't know if you relate to this
feeling but i felt like
as a high schooler i i stayed
in the relationship because from tv and
like a lot of
media i romanticized a lot of the bad
behaviors the erratic like
push and pull of being in like an
abusive relationship where someone's
like
like throwing you down and then lifting
you back up and like doing all of that
stuff
i was like oh i'm i'm on the oc like
this is
like i'm dude i'm marissa cooper it's
happening
you're doing my job for me honestly half
of the people who
i talked to who are like why is my
relationship so boring just need to hear
that
i myself i would say i only broke the
cycle
of abusive relationships not every
single relationship was abusive
uh the non-abusive ones were so boring
or healthy rather that i
would end them uh yeah it's like you
couldn't break into my house and watch
me sleep
like edward cullen or whatever and then
you're like and it's like
no people people get so angry at porn
and i mean
listen there's a lot of [ __ ] up things
that porn reinforces
but i think like non-pornographic film
and tv uh really [ __ ] up our idea of
what romance is supposed to be
and what courtship although
is courtship obsolete yet like i don't
know
um but yeah i i'd say i only
i'm still working through that
programming but
i'd say i only broke the cycle like
three or four years ago
it's hard and i see it all the time and
stuff
from when i was a kid of just like i
felt
like my life had to be
this um a teen drama and then anything
less than that
i was boring i wasn't making a splash in
the world
like because we all need to be making a
splash when we're 15.
exactly exactly and it's like girl also
all the actors on that show
are 30 like you're truly
they're adult people
uh so okay you are a sex educator
now what sex education
did you get in high school where
were you having sex in high school like
where were you at with all of that
yeah i started having sex i mean i would
you know
i was i started having sex when i was 14
but i would say i lost my virginity when
i was 15
which i think for me was way too early
you could never tell a 15 or 14 year old
that it's too soon
because you're just re you're just
making them want to do it more but i
i after that first abusive relationship
did not have sex again until like i had
basically graduated high school
um my sex education
was relatively pretty good
um it was not abstinence only but we
focused on anatomy
and uh
reproduction yeah not not pleasure like
i we might have even talked about
masturbation but i
know for a fact that there was no
discussion
of stuff like the g-spot or just like
sex education that's
that's truly practical like obviously
even the most progressive sex education
is not going to say
here are some nifty moves for touching
your [ __ ] like
they're just never gonna say that
they're never gonna say that
let's get back right right me we're
talking we're making fun of
me okay so you you're
you've got this boyfriend you're
floating not really between
crews what else are you
into at this time is dance team kind of
your whole
life or are you doing the plays anything
like that
no time for anything but dance i not
only had two hours of dance team every
day after school
but at least one of my classes in the
daytime
at school would be dance because it was
like a magnet school for arts
and how so i would you know like wake up
get to school
at 7 00 a.m sweat
and unsweat at some point throughout the
day for dance class
and then it was time for palms and that
was literally
every day for two hours um
i had no social life outside of palms
for that reason
but also i just dan it was school
dance homework bed that was all i did
kept me busy i had a [ __ ] home life
at the time i just i like
hated dancing for two hours a day i
injured myself from it a lot my body is
like
i have angry joints as an adult you know
yeah
it lets me out of the house and
i'm just a high energy person like i
have to move every single day
and that was how i [ __ ] made the time
go by
was the dream like okay i want to go be
a dancer or was it really just like you
know what
i don't i just need to focus on this
because i don't want to be in the house
and there wasn't like a future goal to
it
i wanted to be a dancer i wanted to be a
rockette although like
what i like out of all the dance things
that would probably be my last choice
today because it's the most
militant and robotic [ __ ] ever
but i was really good at specifically a
kick line
uh which was a section in palms we did
kick one
i was really good at it so i was like i
should be a rock hat
so glad that did not happen i was listen
i was just like not good at dance i
trained really hard but i had no natural
talent like i was not
naturally built i did not i do not have
a dancer's body
and it was yeah that's super interesting
so were you
aware at the time were you like you know
what i'm actually not really excelling
at this or were you like
no i'm going to make it raquette's here
i come
it was a slow uh descent into
reality of like just like with the nba
like very few people make it
and i actually had an uncle of mine who
is in showbiz be like you're not gonna
just give up on that dream and i was
just like all right [ __ ] you
okay um and then i think it was junior
year
i was taking ap psychology and i just
[ __ ] loved it i was like i love
people's brains i love the human brain
it's also [ __ ] up i love it
um and then psychology was the goal and
that's what i went to college for
okay so you because my my school had ap
psych
as well which i didn't take but i
remember like
i remember that being like a a common
experience like some kids who took
it just really took to it was it
was just the subject or was there like a
cool was there an inspiring teacher
involved
i mean the teacher was pretty inspiring
he was like a very old jewish man
um who kind of always had a twinkle in
his eye he'd be like
today's episode of the roast of your
teenage self podcast
is brought to you by candice you know
those things we'd love to do for
ourselves but haven't done for
whatever reason for me i always wanted a
straighter
better smile fun fact about me i never
had braces in high school i never got to
have that day where you like you show up
and your braces are off and everyone's
like
oh my god she's so beautiful she looks
amazing i never got
to have that but thanks to candid
straightening my teeth
is simpler easier and more comfortable
than ever candid clear aligners are
comfortable
removable and practically invisible
unlike
braces so you can transform your smile
without
anyone noticing so yeah you know i won't
get that big like
beautiful swan moment at the end of my
candids
but um i just feel like wire braces on a
30 year old woman isn't exactly the look
that i'm going for plus your treatment
is prescribed and monitored remotely by
a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement
and it's all done from the comfort and
convenience of your own home
i am personally beginning my
candid process and i was surprised at
how easy it is to do
literally everything from home they send
you a kit
you get a bunch of silly putty you mold
the silly putty
that mold the silly putty onto your
teeth then you talk to
a dentist and by dentist i mean
orthodontist because they
only work with licensed orthodontists
it's simple it's easy and you can do it
from
your home plus your supervising
orthodontist will be with you
every step of the way with candid your
treatment includes remote monitoring
by that same orthodontist who created
your plan so you never have to wonder
how you're doing
you'll always know i love that
as someone who's never gone through the
orthodontia process
never had a retainer never had braces
yes these are
all brags except not really because now
my teeth aren't straight
i personally love the way they hold your
hand and walk you
through it the average candid treatment
is just six months and you'll start
seeing results
way before then and it costs
thousands less than braces which is part
of the reason why my parents did not
want to buy
me braces they were like your teeth are
all facing forward
you're good start straightening your
teeth today
right now all my listeners can save 75
on candids starter kit go to candico.com
teen self and use the code teen
self that's candid co dot com
slash teen self code teen
self take advantage of this limited time
offer to save
75 on your starter kit candidco
dot com slash teen self code teen cell
how much
random crap do you remember from your
high school classes
a lot a little find out and test your
knowledge with trivia star trivia star
is a free
mobile quiz game that's entertaining and
challenging
you can choose categories like music
sports movies tv
animals and celebrities you know all the
things you took classes in in high
school
and there are over 60 categories to
choose from so there's always
more trivia to explore and if you choose
the correct answer from the multiple
choice and beat the clock
you move on to the next level but if
you're like uh you know what i was
actually
like i got fives on my ap exams that
sounds pretty easy
the levels get harder as time
goes on but if you get stuck don't worry
because you can use coins and gems to
get a hint
at the next level bet you wish you had
that to help you during pop quizzes back
in the day
and trivia star has 2 000
5 star reviews in the apple store join
them today
and see if you are smart enough to win
right now trivia star is offering you
2500 coins and 500 gems when you
download and play
just go to apple or google and search
for
trivia star again search trivia star and
enjoy
2500 coins and 500 gems download trivia
star
for free today
all right let's take a moment because
you sent some great pictures so let's go
through
some of the ones that we have not looked
at yet sure oh
oh you can tell i'm really indie there
you yes this is like your indie
this feels very different stylistically
to me than your
cheerleader years well it was shot on a
dslr can you tell
wow i first of all why am i wearing
white shoes that's
so annoying um second of all
that dress was definitely from urban
outfitters i think that coat was like
some fake fake urban outfitters anyway
this was the well i think that's the
that bridge between alexandria and
dc that's in foggy bottom georgetown dc
right there
and that was a little i used to hang out
with this like skater boy
who i was kinda i remember we met
from the internet i completely forgot
about this
and um we met off of myspace
and you know when someone's just like
super hot on on the internet and you
meet them and you're like
oh no it's one of those hangouts
the first time that happens to you when
you're a teen and you're like
i've i've heard tell of this but i never
i never thought i would be fooled
no it was like i hadn't even heard any
like
online dating story i was it wasn't even
like online dating it was just like
ooh like um we have mutual friends on
myspace or something
hey anyway he took me to this
this was the old on-ramp bridge for that
bridge that's behind me
and i took my girlfriend back there and
we took like
artsy photographs of each other
this was uh probably my senior year i i
tried to give you like a wide range of
teenage years like
those other two were like more 14 and 15
and this is definitely like
17 or 18 here so were you
like a photography girl
and i don't know what i mean
yeah i mean like i took i eventually did
take dark room photography
i took photo in college too so i guess
yes i always loved taking pictures
it's kind of sad how the smartphone also
replaced
that because it was a very intentional
decision like
cameras used to weigh like five pounds
if you had a nice lens like this camera
or you know it was like you had to have
a bag with you
if you wanted to bring your camera so it
was this intentional like
we're going to go take photos today like
yes i remember my really close friend
from high school chelsea was in
the photography classes which like i
could never take the fun electives
because i was always doing like drama
drama drama that was it
my whole life she was in
she was in photography which number one
meant that we could go in the dark room
with her which was like the coolest
thing in the entire world
and number two she would sometimes be
like okay i have to take photog
pictures for my photography class and i
still have some photos of me
like um in like
like black and white and but she like
colored my dress in red and i have a
rose and i'm like in the
like pond area across the street from my
house and it made me feel i was like i'm
a model
it made me feel like the most gorgeous
person in the world
i felt that way as well i really wanted
to uh
actually be a model and but i was i had
the face not the body
see a recurring theme my body just
disqualified me from everything
and i'm sure that felt
good for you no
it was literally like i would i was one
of those [ __ ]
who would like go on model mayhem and be
like mommy i want to shoot with
photographers and it was like a
very sketchy way of shooting pictures
and my mom would be like no absolutely
not look at all the nude pictures on
this photographer's website i'd be like
i don't care mom they want to shoot with
me nobody wants to shoot with me
um this photo
was actually same friend took this
picture as the last one
i guess a good way of summing up my
friendships were like yes i was a
floater
but after sophomore year i rekindled
my like my close best girlfriend
abby who is still my best friend to this
day
um i i had a lot more like one-on-one
friendships never had a friend group
but it was just a lot of one-on-one
hangouts this
was i i think on the 4th of july
which in dc as you know they do the big
like national mall celebration to me the
fourth of july was always just like have
a picnic day
obviously we now you know it's it has a
different meaning as adults
but really nice in dc on the 4th of july
now it's a different subject not so much
yeah uh we did a road trip all over
maryland and we found
the first washington monument again
washington is no person i wish to have a
monument
for in this country but uh it was the
original one before they built the big
penis in washington dc so we were there
and again i was trying to be so cool in
indy although here i'm rocking like some
unique thrift store um
fines as opposed to urban outfitters so
i was i was getting a little bit more
with the program
i was like thrifting that's that's a
thing okay
yeah yeah you you're discovering like
okay
what urban outfitters is trying to make
it feel like i did
this yes yeah oh my god that
that should just be urban outfitters new
slogan you paid a lot
to feel like you thrifted oh this one
you're in new york city
you're going to do a broadcast perhaps
um this was the first year this was like
my first year in college i had moved
to new york i went to fordham university
i think i was on my way to the west
indian day parade
which is my favorite annual thingy in
new york
um i was very inappropriately dressed
for the weather
i was wearing a [ __ ] sweater it was a
hot ass day
um but i just love how like a i look
like a baby
and really like i feel like you look
younger in this picture then you look in
some of the ones
like where you're actually younger
honestly even in like
my my my childhood photos my boyfriend
like we have this joke where he'll just
like look at a picture of me
and i agree and he'll just be like you
look like a 40 year old woman like
trapped in a child's body because like i
was so
unhappy as a child and living at home
most of the time but like
i just look like a depressed person
who's seen some [ __ ]
and like here i am living on my own for
the first time like my first
months of freedom and like it's funny
because i do look like oh
new york a big city
but that's how i felt i felt free
and it was so [ __ ] exciting to be
free
what so what led you to the decision to
go
to fordham were you
were you just like was it new york that
drew you
to fordham or like yeah that was it
scholarship money yes yes yes
yeah i wanted to be far from home but i
had
family i have family in new york and
i just i wanted to be in new york it was
the best school i got into and
they gave me financial aid so i was
there for it
i see i admire that because i think at
that age i
also wanted to be in new york but i was
too scared to like
i still felt like i was like oh but you
couldn't be in
new york so i should have honestly had
more of that attitude because i was such
a reckless
like the way a lot of my friends acted
from age
14 to 18 was how i acted from ages 18 to
22.
because it was this delayed letting go
of all the adolescent energy
not in a physical activity way but like
in a party way like in a making bad
decisions way
i and while i'm obviously not
responsible for anything that happened
to me
like i was easy target i was the
easiest target i had so many things
happen to me especially my first few
years living in new york where
when i go back to new york today i know
how to [ __ ]
not be no i mean again this is something
no a skill no person should have to
acquire
but i don't look like a child anymore
so people don't mess with me and it
makes me so angry that when you look
like
a kid still that's when everybody goes
for you because they know you haven't
[ __ ] learned how to stand up for
yourself yet
and here we go again y'all today's
episode of the roast of your teenage
self podcast is brought to you
by purple okay purple is improving the
way we sleep with their patented
technology the purple grid it's the only
comfort innovation that provides
total pressure relief absolute air flow
and ergonomic support
that's because the grid's open air
channels adapt to your natural shape
while neutralizing body heat so you stay
comfortably
cool all night yes here we are
again where i remind you that
prior to purple's entrance in my life
i was sweating in my sleep i was
sweating in
my sleep but the purple grid sets the
purple mattress apart from
every other mattress because its
patented comfort technology
instantly adapts to your body's natural
shape
and sleep style and purple provides a
cooling effect
that other mattresses can't replicate
this cutting to edge technology doesn't
stop with mattresses
okay it doesn't stop with mattresses the
purple pillow
is engineered with the grid for total
head and neck support and absolute
airflow
so you're always on the cool side
of the pillow look at your pillows on
your bed okay
take a look at them say am i sleeping on
some crap
pillows because recently me and my
fiance realized
we were sleeping on some crap pillows
okay flimsy
nasty where did we get them we couldn't
even figure out where they came from but
not
anymore because we have the purple
pillow
and purple pillows proprietary
technology has been innovating
comfort for over 15 years
and i i see it every day when i lay my
beautiful head down
on my purple pillow and i think about
the time that i spent
laying my head down stacking up nasty
flip-floppity pillows
when i could just have one one gorgeous
purple pillow and you can try every
purple product
risk free with free shipping and returns
and purple has financing available as
low as zero percent apr for qualified
customers
experience the purple grid and you'll
sleep like never before
go to purple.com teen self and use promo
code
teen self for a limited time and you'll
get 10
off any order of 200 or more
that's purple.com teen self promo code
teen
self for 10 off any order of 200
or more terms apply
yeah and it's when you're that young i
feel like when i when you're 18 and
you're about to go to college
you feel like such an adult and like
you're in this process of you're like
finally freeing yourself from your
parents home
you like you've been in survival mode
throughout high school just trying to
deal with
being in your parents home you're
finally free and you don't even realize
that you look like a baby to everyone
you think that you look like all these
other like badass [ __ ] that are
walking down the street in their heels
and their stilettos like
doing their ceo jobs in the financial
district and you actually look
like a little baby
yeah i definitely oh yeah that's
that's probably the best one i'd say uh
this we're going back to definitely age
there that was before i'd even met my
boyfriend because this was
um do you remember i don't know if if
giant
was in oh yeah yeah it's like safeway
but giant was a
grocery store chain for those of you who
didn't live in the
dc area um it was winter
and this was my first set of friends
when i did have like a tiny little
friend group in the beginning
and we all lived in like the
burtonsville
area so
one of them there was like a horse
stable
that was near her house and i remember
we walked to the horse stable
we petted a bunch of the horses i'm sure
we were like definitely trespassing
and then we were like let's go get some
cookies and then we were like oh my god
zoey
take a picture in the period aisle oh my
god
like like the funniest thing you can
imagine
is the funniest thing i could imagine at
the time
i also have pictures with my friends
just like
messing around in the aisle at giant
[ __ ] yeah giant was uh truly lawless
literally oh my god i remember like
i remember they had a toy they had like
a toy aisle
and there was this one year that they
had these barbies
that they were storing in the toy aisle
that you could record on the barbie for
it to say stuff
oh what did you do
my friends found out that out like we
would go to giant
every day and have the barbie to just be
like ass
like honestly that's pretty funny
and if i was at a store where you could
pre-record something i would expect
nothing less right
yeah my version also
so that anyone can do it anyone can
record on the barbie
ass they should know better by now
okay zoey this has been amazing i think
we had fun
to the end here so i like to i like to
end every episode
um by asking if you could give a message
to teenage zoey if you could tell her
anything what would you tell her
god that [ __ ] makes me want to cry
you are safe and
you will be free
and you don't have to prove anything to
anybody
and you will be independent one day
that's beautiful yeah teenage zoey you
will be
you are safe you are free and you will
be independent
one day and you don't have to prove
anything to anybody which i think is a
huge
feeling through i was like i was so
obsessed with getting permission from
people to do anything that i wanted to
do like to be in new york
or to say i wanted to do a comedy or
entertainment
like i was so nervous to say i wanted to
do those things
yeah i think i still am learning a
little bit
and i'm 28 now this
i mean there's coronavirus but i would
be doing my 10-year
high school reunion or whatever this
year i think i guess it's been about
time
it's been exactly 10 years since i
graduated and
uh i don't know where i was going with
that
i just think it's uh it's an interesting
milestone
i feel like being
so close to 30 is
just exciting and not scary and
i am excited to get more wrinkles on my
face
so i can be like look how wise i
am god damn it i've seen some [ __ ] and
i'm not
a child with an old person stuck inside
of them anymore i'm
actually just an older older person now
well zoe it was amazing to have you on
the podcast
uh it was great talking to you and you
too
the best concept for a podcast ever if
you asked oh i'm so glad
i'm glad i'm glad that this worked out
and that we could connect online
absolutely
and for everybody at home this has been
the roast of your teenage self podcast
you